Hey there. I'm Jonathan Levav,
Professor of Marketing at the Stanford Graduate School of Business.
As you may have guessed from the title of this video,
throughout our marketing mini series,
I'm going to review concepts to help you identify new marketing opportunities.
So what is marketing?
Many people hear the word marketing and think it's a synonym for advertising or sales.
But ads in sales are just one tactical component of the marketing process.
What marketing really is,
is the process of determining the needs and wants of customers and
delivering the desired benefits more effectively and efficiently than competitors,
in order to achieve organizational goals.
You see marketing in action every day,
products and services you love,
ads on the television or the Web, promotions,
end of aisle displays in grocery stores,
promo e-mails, mailings, targeted ads, marketing is everywhere.
You might be staring right at marketing and not even know it.
Like for example this video.
It's part of a marketing effort for our innovation certificate program here at Stanford.
Out there in the world, you might see the stickers used to identify Uber or Lyft drivers,
smell fragrances in stores,
hear music in malls,
note the chill vibe of a retail space or coffee shop,
find store brands stock near national brands,
experience stores that don't even sell you anything.
These are all actually examples of marketing.
Marketing is at the heart of a new product launch for one simple reason,
successful products meet consumer needs,
and they do it better than the competition.
Marketing is the crucial function in a firm that
enables us to determine and understand what consumers need.
There is no launching a product without marketing, period.
So join us in this mini series to learn new tips and
examples of how companies like YouTube and Waze,
and even individuals like Snoop Dogg use marketing successfully.